minds were blown and jaws were dropped
marbles were lost and social media sites
were nearly broken after Marvel
announced its face for slate at San
Diego comic-con 2019 here's what
delighted fans on Twitter had to say
about each upcoming face for project
directed by Kate Shortland and featuring
Scarlett Johansson's iconic superhero
the black would have solo movie
announcement hack fans pumped
Martha lights are thrilled Black Widow
is finally getting a standalone film
which will begin the MCU space for when
it hits theaters on May 1st 2020 one fan
wrote we are less than a year away from
a Black Widow solo film and I am
honestly shook to my core Natasha
deserved her own movie from the get-go a
fellow Black Widow fan felt much the
same tweeting crying but happy crying to
hear officially Black Widow finally
getting her own standalone movie
Scarlett Johansson girl bring it in this
solo movie I could care less what others
say this is truly amazing I can't wait
to see this Marvel movie in theaters May
1st 2020 hurl power
directed by Chloe Zhou and centered on a
race of cosmic immortal beings the
Eternals features a diverse all-star
cast the star-studded roster sent fans
into a tailspin as did it's confirmed
release date of November 6 2021 fan
tweeted damn the cast of Eternals a
straight-up fire it's perfect
Angelina Jolie Richard Madden and Kumail
Nanjiani the excellence we're about to
enter a whole new era of superheroes
another added it is a mildly emotional
moment to see this cast the
representation of people of color and
women in this film in front and behind
the camera is crazy I can't wait to see
this director Dustin Daniel [ __ ]
shang-chi in the legend of the ten rings
based on Marvel's master of Kung Fu
garnered a similar response from fans
Chinese Canadian actors C mu Lee you
will be the MCU shang-chi a role he
actually reached out to Marvel about
playing via Twitter the film due out in
theaters on February 12 2021 will
feature a predominantly Asian cast
alongside Li Yu's martial arts master
one user wrote in response to the news
Marvel now has a film with all Asian
actors in it
come on Asian representation a twitter
user by the
name of William you was especially moved
by the shang-chi reveal writing as a kid
I couldn't have even imagined a
superhero movie with Asian leaves I
can't believe it's really happening
the movement is real it's not stopping
representation matters today Marvel fans
went mad over the news that Benedict
Cumberbatch's dr. Stephen strange is
finally getting a sequel with the Scott
Derek directed Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness coming our way on
May 7th 2021 a particular note amongst
Marvel lights were three things the
film's title that suggests the existence
of the multiverse and the MCU the
announcement that Elizabeth Olsen
Scarlet Witch will play a part in the
story and Erickson's promised that the
Doctor Strange sequel would be a
legitimate horror movie one fan wrote
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness logo nine out of ten hype AF
horror Elizabeth Olsen
plus Doctor Strange this looks
incredible give me more of that crazy
mystic dimension Doctor Strange is Loki
one of my favorites and I'm super
looking forward to this one another fan
tweeted pretty much everything marble
announced today is super intriguing
they're clearly headed in a much more
comic book E direction and I'm hyped
this one excites me most of all Doctor
Strange magic and Wanda's magic and the
multiverse of madness what more could I
ask for the fifth phase for film
announced at San Diego comic-con also
has a totally campy title the word love
and thunder but don't be fooled by the
name the fourth Thor flick
written and directed by Ragnarok Helmer
Taika Waititi will pack a serious punch
with the introduction of Natalie
Portman's Jane Foster is the female Thor
plus the confirmation that Tessa
Thompson's new Asgard ruler Valkyrie is
bisexual making her the first openly
LGBTQ plus superhero in the MCU
understandably fans freaked out over the
reveal of Thor love and thunder
scheduled to hit theaters on November
5th 2021 I'll listen to you till this is
empty one wrote Natalie Portman is back
as female Thor Tessa Thompson said
Valkyrie wants a girlfriend because as
the new king of Asgard she needs her
queen Thor four is gonna be awesome and
lovely elsewhere in the Twittersphere
another fan said that their most keen on
Thor love and thunder out of all the
phase four
he's announced Thor 11 Thunder excites
me the most
Tyko ytt is director and writer allowing
him to take it in his own insane way the
brilliant town / structure created in
Ragnarok now combined with the return of
Natalie Portman as female Thor sounds
like a match made in heaven as for the
five Marvel superhero shows coming to
the Disney Plus streaming site people
had a whole lot of feelings tweeting
about the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
featuring Anthony Mackie and Sebastian
Stan reprising their MCU roles one fan
wrote the idea of this is interesting
and I can't wait to see what the story
will revolve around many were hyped
about whan division is sure to be
strange limited series starring
Elizabeth Olsen as Wanda Maximoff aka
Scarlet Witch Paul Bettany as vision and
Tiana Paris as Monica Rambeau one fan
tweeted their guests of what the show
which Marvel Studios President Kevin
Feige said is weird and wacky and unlike
anything more Vil has done before might
be like I feel like one division is
going to be kind of a mix between House
of M and the 2015 Vision comic and it's
going to be great also I don't know what
Monica Rambeau would do in a show like
this but I am so excited Tom
Hiddleston's Loki series got fans in a
tizzy as well with many tweeting that
they're so happy the actor is getting to
reprise his role as an Avengers era Loki
getting mixed up in all sorts of
adventures one fan even addressed
Hiddleston directly writing I'm so happy
for you and I'm really excited about
Loki TV series it's gonna be good to see
you again
while another extremely excited fan
tweeted Tom Hiddleston is Loki and
finally getting his own series Wow truly
the most powerful thing I've ever heard
of and will witness please it's going to
be so amazing I'm so excited you don't
even know
[Applause]
stirring jeremy renner is the
sharpshooting hero
the Hawkeye series has fans excited for
its inclusion of Kate Bishop Clint
Barton's successor whom he'll train on
the show Marvel hasn't yet announced
which actress will play Kate and take on
the Hawkeye mantle when Clint steps down
but that hardly matters fans are already
buzzing one fan tweeted Oh a Hawkeye
series this is amazing I'm very hyped
for MCU Hawkeye
he's so underutilized in the movies
except endgame and I really wanted
Marvel to explore a good character
mourner now it's finally his time to
shine Marvel also unveiled the first
ever animated series on the MCU what-if
premiering on Disney Plus in the summer
of 2021 the show narrated by Jeffrey
Wright as the non earthly being the
watcher and featuring the voices of
several MCU favorites will add a twist
to the 23 movie infinity saga one fan
tweeted can't wait to see Marvel Studios
first venture into animation I have high
expectations can't wait to get you a -
The Watcher glad this is being treated
as an important part of the slate just
like everything else love what-if
scenarios writer Erik vespi was
incredibly intrigued by the reveal of
what-if tweeting this is one of my most
anticipated projects on the Marvel slate
I grew up obsessed with these books a
lot of times I liked the what-if stories
better than the actual real ones can't
wait to see what direction the animation
is going cartoony like Clone Wars or
hyper real strap in for phase 4 of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe starting with
Black Widow on May 1st 2020 and be sure
to keep your arms and legs inside the
moving vehicle until it comes to a stop
with Thor 11 Thunder on November 5th
2021 check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about the MCU are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you